NEED TO BE INCARCERATED.
>> JONATHAN SERRIE LIVE IN THE
JOYA TEXAS.
SOUTH DAKOTA GOVERNOR KRISTI
NOEM HAS ASKED HER STATE TO SEND
NATIONAL GUARD MEMBERS TO ASSIST
AT THE BORDER.
SHE JOINS US FROM CPAC WHERE SHE
SPOKE MOMENTS AGO, GOVERNOR,
WELCOME.
>> THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME.
>> THE THEME OF THE SPEECH WAS
JOE BIDEN’S AMERICA, FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO DIDN’T GET TO
PERCEIVE YOU PERFORM, WOULD YOU
LAYOUT THE KEY POINTS.
>> I TALKED ABOUT THE VERY
DIFFERENT WORLD WERE LIVING IN
TODAY THAN THE ONE I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GROW UP IN AND I
TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT WERE
SEEING CROM CRIME, LAWLESSNESS A
OPEN BORDER THAT IS DEVASTATING
FAMILIES AND BUSINESSES AND
JEOPARDIZING OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY.
I TALKED ABOUT THE DECISION TO
SEND MY NATIONAL GUARD DOWN TO
THE BORDER I WAS THE FIRST
GOVERNOR IN THE COUNTRY IN TEXAS
AND ARIZONA ASKED FOR HELP I
SENT NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS THAT
KNOW HOW TO COMPLETE MISSIONS,
THEY ARE TRAINED AND EQUIPPED IN
THEIR THE BEST, WE TALKED ABOUT
THAT AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
TAKING THE START SERIOUSLY AND
ALSO PUSHING BACK IN CRITICAL
RACE THEORY, 1619 PROJECT, THOSE
ARE TWO WAYS THAT THEY WILL
QUICKLY DESTROY AMERICA IF WE DO
NOT STOP THEM.
MIKE: YOU MENTIONED SENDING
NATIONAL GUARDSMEN TO THE BORDER
ABOUT 120 LIVE FROM SOUTH DAKOTA
DO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF WHEN THEY
WILL LEAVE AND WHAT THEIR ROLE
WILL BE.
>> I SENT 50 AT THE REQUEST OF
GOVERNOR ABBOTT TO TEXAS
ORIGINALLY, THEY HAVE READY LEFT
I SENT THEM OFF A FEW DAYS AGO
AND THEY’RE CURRENTLY AT THE
BORDER HELPING SECURE THAT IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH BORDER PATROL
AGENTS AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS, WHAT WAS INTERESTING
AS SOON AS I ANNOUNCED I WAS
SENDING NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS IT
WAS DAYS LATER THAT THE WHITE
HOUSE AND THE PENTAGON ASKED US
TO SEND MORE.
ANOTHER 125 REQUEST CAME FORWARD
THEY HAVE SINCE WITH MORE
RESOURCES AS WELL, IT’S
INTERESTING TO ME THAT AS SOON
AS GOVERNORS TOOK THE STAND FOR
NATIONAL SECURITY THAT IT
APPEARS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
GOT THE MESSAGE THAT THEY BETTER
DO THEIR JOB BECAUSE OTHERS WILL
STEP INTO IF THEY WON’T.
MIKE: YOU A LONG RESUME FOR
TERMS ON CAPITOL HILL OF MY
MEMORY IS CORRECT, YOU’RE ALSO A
CEO OF READING THE STATE OF
SOUTH DAKOTA AND SEEN AS A
POTENTIAL PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
AND A WHOLE LOT ABUZZ ABOUT TO
THESE DAYS, IF YOU WERE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE RIGHT NOW WHAT MORE
WOULD YOU DO TO ADDRESS THE
CRISIS THAT ARE BORDER.
>> I WOULD GET THE RESOURCES
DOWN THERE TO MAKE SURE IT IS
SECURE.
I WOULD ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO NOT ILLEGAL’S
INTO THIS COUNTRY THAT WE WOULD
CONTINUE TO ENFORCE OUR LAWS
WITHOUT A BORDER, WE ARE NOT A
COUNTRY, THAT IS WHO JOE BIDEN
IS DOING TO DEVASTATE OUR FUTURE
AS A FREE AND DEFENSIVE NATION.
THE BIGGEST JOBS THAT HAVE BEEN
THE MOST PROUD OF IS RUNNING
BUSINESSES, BEING A MOTHER, A
WIFE AND OUR GRANDMOTHER AND I
THINK THE PERSPECTIVE THAT I
HAVE FROM ALL OF THOSE INCLUDING
CONGRESS AND THE GOVERNOR GIVES
UP THE OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN
AND AWAY TO REFLECT WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT, THEY WANT
SOMEBODY WHO WILL STEP UP EVERY
SINGLE DAY AND DEFEND THE
COUNTRY THAT THEY LOVE SO MUCH.
MIKE: YOUR GRANDKIDS ARE BLESSED
TO HAVE SUCH A GRANDMOTHER,
CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT, YOUR
THOUGHTS AS YOU INTERACT WITH
FOLKS AT CPAC, WHAT YOU HEAR
FROM A LOYAL CONSERVATIVES.
>> I THINK THEY ARE READY TO
CONTINUE TO PUSH THIS COUNTRY TO
REMAIN INDEPENDENT ONE OF THE
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITIES, ONE
OF FREEDOM AND LIBERTY THAT HELD
OUR TRUE AND HONEST HISTORY.
THEIR OPTIMISTIC, HELPFUL, THEY
ARE NOT DISCOURAGED AT ALL, THEY
RECOGNIZE THE THREAT THAT WE SEE
COMING OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT
THEY ALSO RECOGNIZE CONSERVATIVE
VALUES ARE WHAT BUILT THE
COUNTRY AND IT CREATES
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL PEOPLE.
THAT IS A MESSAGE THAT WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO CARRY TO
EVERYONE, NOT JUST OUR FRIENDS
WE NEED TO CARRY IT TO THOSE
THAT WE DISAGREED WITH IN THE
PAST AND MAKE SURE WE WIN THEIR
HEARTS AND MINDS BACK.
MIKE: YET A RECENT CLASS WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WITH THE
FIREWORK SHOW AT MOUNT RUSHMORE,
DO YOU THINK THAT WAS PAYBACK
BECAUSE YOU HAD PRESIDENT TRUMP
OUT THERE A YEAR AGO.
>> I DO, I FEEL SPECIFICALLY
POLITICAL AND PUNITIVE, THERE
WAS NO VALID REASON TO DENY US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CELEBRATE
INDEPENDENCE DAY AT OUR NATIONAL
MONUMENT THAT WE ARE ALSO PROUD
OF, IT’S UNFORTUNATE I AM
CURRENTLY SUING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OVER THAT DECISION
AND HOPEFUL WE CAN RETURN THOSE
FIREWORKS NEXT YEAR.
MIKE: GOVERNOR KRISTI NOEM OF